the dust to settle the bad guys have
been defeated and all is right with the
Marvel Cinematic Universe now that
spider-man homecoming has finally made
Peter Parker an official part of the MCU
but while homecoming answered some
questions it posed a few more especially
with the way it ended he is a spoiler
filled explanation of just what the
ending of spider-man homecoming means
the press-conference
Peter turning down Tony Stark's offer of
membership in the Avengers was a bit of
a surprise but it also had some hidden
meaning
not to mention implications for future
films fans of the comics probably
recognized that the press-conference
sequence closely mirrored a similar
event and the comic book version of
civil war where Peter joins Iron Man
side and reveals a secret identity to
the world luckily in the movie Peter
turns down Starks offer because in the
comics it eventually led to a deal with
the devil dodged a bullet there Spidey
more importantly for film fans Peters
non-membership in the Avengers sets up
some interesting questions heading into
2018 s Avengers infinity war just what
will Spidey's role be in the movie if
he's not a member of the team will he
have a central role or just be relegated
to a cameo whether he's on the team or
not he is hoping we get to see a lot
more of Tom Holland spider-man in the
future pizzas love life at the end of
the film Peters love interest Liz moved
to Oregon but more importantly for fans
we learn that his acerbic classmate
Michelle is actually the MCU version of
Mary Jane Watson who has traditionally
been spider-man's true love considering
there's no sign yet of Gwen Stacy in the
MCU it seems as though Marvel may be
skipping Gwen's tragic death in the same
way they decided to skip Uncle Ben's
death
[Music]
boring sinkhole Peters relationship with
MJ develops in future films should be
interesting the guy in the chair one of
the coolest parts of spider-man
homecoming was pizzas relationship with
his awesomely nerdy best bro
Ned Leeds aka his guy in the chair one
thing though
he might also become one of spider-man's
deadliest super villains that's because
in the comics and Ned leads eventually
becomes a Hobgoblin and if that plot
sounds a little too close to the stories
in the previous spider-man films where
Peters best friend Harry became the
Green Goblin there's a good reason in
the comics Hobgoblin was born when Ned
Leeds found a stash of the deceased
green Goblin's weapons and gizmos of
course comics bean comics that was later
retro actively changed Bert's will Ned
do a heel turn in the movies and become
pitas mortal foe we sure hope not but we
wouldn't put anything past Marvel those
other super villains while the vulture
ended up in prison it was less clear
what happened to the film's other super
villains the shocker and the tinkerer
but chances are pretty good we'll be
seeing them in the future films
especially since the mid-credits teaser
hinted at the creation of the
supervillain team known as the sinister
six which in the past has included both
vulture and of the shocker and with the
Tinker Oh still out there making
supervillain suits introducing other
members of the sinister six like the
Scorpion and the beetle should be easy
what's the big deal with the plane
considering the big lecture Tony Stark
gave Peter about the recklessness of
starting a fight of the vulture on the
Staten Island Ferry had seemed even more
dangerously reckless when Peter nearly
crashed a plane into a Brooklyn
neighborhood just to stop a vulture from
making off with some of Tony sods
leftover junk didn't Spidey learn
anything
with great power comes great
responsibility but there are two pretty
big reasons why Peter actually did the
right thing
the tesseracts an Ultron in both
Avengers and Avengers 2 age of Ultron
the earth was nearly destroyed when the
good guys lost control of massively
powerful goodies they were safeguarding
there's no telling what might have
happened the vulture had been able to
sell stuff like the Hulkbuster armor and
the Thor's magic belt to psychopathic
supervillains
- even though Peter endangered thousands
of lives to save an unmanned plane he
may have actually saved millions of
innocent people in the process the x-men
and the Fantastic Four with homecoming
Marvel proved it can make better
spider-man movies and Sony so imagine
what they could do if they teamed up
with Fox to make a Fantastic Four movie
the success of homecoming may
theoretically make that possible right
now Fox isn't making a dime from
Fantastic Four or other related
properties like Silver Surfer even
splitting the proceeds with Marvel that
make a lot more cash co producing an MCU
Fantastic Four film than they ever will
on their own but could spur Fox and
Marvel to borrow the hatchet and bring
the FF and possibly even the x-men into
the MCU fold and if spider-man can help
reunite all of Marvel's heroes in one
film universe that would be his greatest
feat of heroism yet thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]